[Music]
we're gonna be talking about genetic it
it's gonna be great
who the hell is taking a shirt off in
the gym I do have a rule about more
shortlist at the gym
stop it keep your clothes on you don't
need to be on your chest naked no shoes
no shirt no service get out man if
that's something you want to do that
just gives me a distraction to laugh at
you and then you probably don't even
wipe the back of the seat
don't want your sweaty sweat your
parents should have taught you better
yeah I think it's slowly fine I feel
like if you're not Gretton uee trying to
fail and that's the whole point of being
in the gym
you got a grunt like you know you got to
get like that real guttural deep I can't
stand it do it but I hate it it's almost
like watching wrestling in the 80s you
know and I mean it's like the deeper
your voice is and the boy you grunt the
more powerful you are I also think it is
a sign of low intelligence so don't do
it
[Music]
every yoga class I do is a horror story
I'm always in the back but they have
mirrors so they can see you I need
everybody gone you know I'm doing splits
and then they getting too close to
looking at me too much I don't like this
woman in front of me was feeling very
comfortable and she farted like woah
okay
my nose was maybe it wasn't this close
but it was probably this close I started
coughing and then spit up and then like
had to like crawl out of the class and
all like people next to me like that at
the gym I was trying to spend it was one
of my first classes and I just couldn't
really find the rhythm and all of a
sudden it felt like I was kind of
distracting from this class trying to
figure out my whole soul cycle situation
I didn't go back in
I left my mat it's still there don't
tell her she look good don't ask her
about her workout girls do not like when
you're staring at them at the gym she's
not stupid we stupid everybody wants to
work out in peace so don't interrupt
that you need to be smelling good while
you're in the gym even if you sweat you
know some people like well you know I'm
gonna show afterwards so what's the
point just the point is so you don't
anger me while you're next to me doing
shoulder presses I don't want the
dissent to hit me like that
put some dealing on lather in that [ __ ]
[Music]
I love my body but uh lebron james died
be nice to have his because he's very
durable kai greene just cuz the dude is
320 pounds of just solid muscle
I feel Viking nobody-nobody
Colin Kapernick in his prime as a part
of the gym is like you could add a
tricep you could add a track you can
create the body that you want to create
if you hit the gym appropriate ease this
has been proper gym etiquette for all
the lovely people GP it once again those
are my rules you do not have to follow
them but I would appreciate it if you do
because we real serious at the gym but
don't be too serious because nobody
likes that person either you know
[Music]